nobody try to steal it please i'll have
a heart attack
hide the serial number everything what's
up gq this is romeo this is matt
champion mr barf
it's merlin this is dom bear facebook
i'm joe buff this is kevin abstract from
brockhampton
[Music]
this is energy he goes everywhere
with me he's definitely one of the
favorite new members to brockhampton
i got him on may 7th so about like a
year and three days ago
he really is the first like i've ever
owned i can relate a lot to snoop dogg
now that i'm a dog father
it has a lot of ups and downs like i
understand when people say they enjoy
other people's dogs and other people's
kids because like
the dog is a lot cuter when you don't
gotta pick up his crap
he's still cute though he's still really
cute
i've been on the plane with him it was a
little tough as soon as i got on the
plane i fell asleep
and then the next thing i know someone
was like waking me up he's like bro like
your dog escaped i'm like where's my dog
and he is definitely like under
somebody's seat like
licking them or something
i brought for my central
fingerboard been fingerboarding since i
was a young man and it's kind of stuck
with me the whole time
this isn't a tactic it's quite different
it's wooden
it's the real ones i got really good at
it and i don't remember how
and it's the only thing i feel like i
can brag about and i can back it up
[Music]
man well i have one on right now but you
know we call it daca's in the caribbean
i'm from grenada
you know your shade i need these you
know why i use them
because i block out all the you put them
on
the budget is gone sometimes you might
be in a little emo mode
sometimes you don't want to be talking
having to explain yourself
put these on your walk in the room
what's up
go on about your business sometimes i
have the ones that you know your daytime
glasses with the colored frames then i
have
like this one perfect for
when you don't want to say nothing just
walk in
no one can see your eyes no one can read
you it's perfect because sometimes i
ain't want to be red
going to the supermarket i'm gonna have
these on you know i could be going to
the bank and i have these on
walking my dog i'm gonna always have it
on because sometimes i just wanna
be in my zone you know like i said when
you don't have them
people always bother you when you have
it on
they're like oh that's a cool guy man
i'ma just say what's up tim
and keep it pushing
[Music]
okay so my essential item is a hoodie
this is um a family picture this is on
my parents wedding hoodies are like my
favorite clothes to wear
and i just like i'm always wearing
hoodie i'm wearing hoodie right now
usually
either i'm wearing a hoodie or there's
one in the car i don't know something
very safe
about hoodies and i like them
how many hoodies would you say you have
in your collection
unholy amount um i like i pretty much
only wear hoodies like
just like i would say maybe at least
40 to 60 in my house
my best friend pluto he's the uh the
sweetest boy in the world
he is a french bulldog boxer mix
he's a frenchie boxer mix yeah
good boy he's a gq man himself as you
can see with his fresh fit got his car
hard on
but he's actually my um my girlfriend's
dog and then
i guess i'm his stepdad but for my
birthday a couple years ago she gave me
adoption paper so i'm like his legal dad
now if i'm not making music i'm probably
just on the couch with him
all the time we took him to a modeling
agency once and they said he's too edgy
but now he's in gq so
this is my passport it's got my visa in
it so if i lose this
i'm [ __ ] if i lose this basically my
only form of id
don't have a driver's license i keep it
in a drawer
and i like always make i like check
every day i'm like put it back okay
because i
like sometimes if i need it if i'm like
going somewhere i'll need like id
someone was like all right it's my right
pocket like and i'll like check
throughout the day like okay it's here
like
if i lose it like having to go through
the process we're gonna be
again it's like a nightmare i couldn't
think of anything more essential
so
today i brought these cool glasses i
like to wear
these uh bottega shades i feel like i'm
in the future
i used to be like really ashamed of
wearing sunglasses i felt like it made
me feel mad corny but
i realized that through wearing them it
kind of
feels like uh like when i used to like
go around wearing this helmet all the
time
like like this extra shield of safety or
something
and it also makes me feel like you know
i'm just hanging out in the future or
something so
yeah for insecure people like me uh the
mask or glasses add like
this wild level of confidence to my
everyday life
i had to pull out my trusty lawn chair
i'm actually sitting in it right now
it's beautiful green kind of old school
classic americano
backyard you know if you're sitting at
the barbecue
the kids are playing you know
sipping your beverage of choice in that
summer sun
it's a great place to pop squat
and sometimes i'll slow smoke a brisket
for like 12 plus hours and this is this
is great to have because you can just
watch the fire watch the you know the
meat thing
cook it's relaxing
this is my laptop my macbook we record
every song on there
before the pandemic we would tour like
well like eight months out the year six
pretty much yeah the majority of the
year we were so
just like set up a studio in every hotel
room
green room wherever and this was always
like the foundation of that
everything that ends up getting recorded
in some way shape or form that the world
is hearing is
on this thing somehow in some way shape
or form beyond like
it connecting us together though like
this little thing here is what keeps us
going for real for real like
all the songs are there and here it
makes us want to keep going makes us
want to stop
brings us all back together tears us
apart it's true
educates us jabari you know he'll have
his own laptop set up with all his
sounds
and vsts and plug-ins because bar he
likes to like really lock in his ideas
and make sure they're
you know exactly how he wants him before
he presents unfortunately
but even his ideas will
be funneled into romeo's computer what's
your dog choice
i was actually going to bring the
ableton box so oh my god that's a great
essential okay that's what we've been
using primarily for the past
couple of years is ableton but a couple
of people in the group use know how to
use different things i'm pretty sure
that
karen uses logic pro still exclusively
right yeah
joba was in pro tools for a while i
think at this point we've all developed
a technological
jargon to communicate our ideas
carefully and precisely and ultimately
just have a musical conversation with
and without words
i mean i have all of them because to me
it's just like different languages
kobe spoke four languages him and paul
gasol spoke italian on the court
you know so you have to be able to
communicate with the other teammates in
their language
thanks we're not italian i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry spanish
he knew italian because he grew up in
italy sorry
our final essential is uh our manager
kelly clancy whoa
she's currently standing off frame
because she doesn't like being on camera
but uh
nothing uh involving broadcasting gets
done without kelly's involvement we love
kelly
she keeps us together she keeps us on
track i talk to her every day
multiple times a day i mean my mom and
her best friends it's like
real
[Applause]
guys would do family a manager without
kelly's guidance
what would we do without a manager
without kelly without kelly
oh we'd be complete failures we'd be
broke
thank you guys for watching this was
brockhampton's 10th essentials see you
next time